non ce n'est ni une voiture de james
bond une formule 1 mais bien un véhicule
de la gendarmerie française l'élu la
voici l'alpine a110 choisi pour équiper
les équipes rapides d'intervention la
gendarmerie nationale et les bolides de
course l'histoire d'amour dure depuis 50
ans
direction de lyon en vue d'intercepter
le véhicule
fin des années 60 l'alpine a110 débarque
sur les routes de france au volant des
pilotes d'un nouveau genre les gendarmes
coiffé d'un casque lunettes de soleil
sur le nez
ces voitures rapides nous permettent
comme vous avez pu le voir de rattraper
une personne en infraction mais elles
nous servent également à conseiller les
gens en cours de route albine sm
maserati pas facile de conduire de tels
bolides alors les gendarmes de la
brigade rapide d'intervention sont triés
sur le volet ces pilotes sont d'abord
d'anciens motocyclistes et d'excellents
conducteurs ils subissent premièrement
une visite médicale ces importantes et
ensuite ils suivent un stage sur le
circuit bugatti au mans dans les années
80 la gendarmerie se dote de nouveaux
véhicules découvrez-les alpines des 6
turbo plus puissante offerte par renault
vitesse de pointe 235 km heure
ça
[Musique]
en 1987 elles sont huit à sillonner les
autoroutes françaises leur mission
sécuriser les accidents et arrêter les
chauffards pour les gendarmes fini le
casque sur la tête la sto képi à noter
la pointe de ressemblance avec un
célèbre duo policiers de la télé des
années 70 est-ce qu'on peut être vous
êtes les stars kate français non vous
savez il faut laisser ça aux gens qui le
pense moi je me considère tout
simplement comme un gendarme après
l'albine la renault 21 turbo dans les
années 90 puis la subaru wrx en 2006 à
l'intérieur c'est le futur les panneaux
d'information lumineux disponible en
cinq langues à l'extérieur son design
tape-à-l'oeil repérable à des kilomètres
à la ronde et jolie voiture
données turbocompressé c'est efficace on
arrive de suite on est au contact du
contrevenant dernier bijou de la
gendarmerie la renault mégane rs arriver
en 2011 en bout de course elle va faire
ses adieux prochainement pour la
remplacer la gendarmerie va revenir à
ses premiers amours l'alpine a110 26
exemplaires ont été commandés et devrait
arriver sur les routes cours en 2022
[Musique]